geeksplus is a youtube channel now our
boss isn't definitely holding us at
gunpoint help me please go check it out
for some amazing moments like this
guys my mom won't give me dinner unless
you guys check it out and by my mum i
mean mailing off screen right now
they're withholding our paychecks until
you go and click on their channel
i haven't seen my girlfriend in three
days
please subscribe i've been wearing the
same shirt for four weeks eileen won't
buy me a new one until you check it out
go go check the link in the description
please go check it out please help
someone's taking such a massive [ __ ]
that they've clogged up the top toilet i
took a [ __ ] downstairs i mean i think i
took a [ __ ] like drowsy you might have
to sort that out
what's up you zesty zymolatic zoologist
zoologist
there's like one out there watching us
right now yeah he's like i'm zesty i'm
zymolatic and i'm a zoologist thank you
joey welcome back to another episode of
trash taste i'm joey with garden corner
i don't think i've ever met a single
zoologist yet yet
[Music]
they'll be the one comment
there's going to be that one comment
being like zesty's analytics all just
i'm right here i'm right here geologist
i i know zoologist i wouldn't be
surprised if you knew one because i feel
like in australia there's there's a lot
more zoologists
because it's next door
every time a snake pops up is like
someone call a zoologist and ted is like
yeah all right [ __ ] let's have a look
at this yeah you're all right you're
right she'll be all right
i've never met someone who does stuff
with zoos that is sad
what do you mean people who work you've
never met a depressed zoologist people
who like work with animals are always
like the most chill happiest people to
be fair
i would be pretty happy as well if i
could work with animals yeah when you
hear about these like they're always in
australia like yeah we walk on the coast
and they're just like they're like help
coral or some [ __ ] and they're just
always like super happy like yeah you
just saved the coral
i love it you know what kind of message
will they be presenting if they're like
superstars
you know like turns out
planets dying is [ __ ] annoying yeah
[ __ ] kangaroos out of my backyard i
don't know i feel like i feel like
you're either like happy that you're
working with animals that you like to be
around right uh because you've chosen to
be in that
profession or i mean like the the only
thing i can think of is people who work
with like venomous animals or something
like that or animals that can put you in
danger and but if that's the case you
have to be someone who's enthusiastic
yeah they love you
they [ __ ] love it right like oh don't
don't put the crocodile too hard yeah
i'm gonna chuck it yeah i'm gonna jump
on it yeah it's like it's like those
videos of like the those like you know
venomous like snake and spider
collectors they just like every time
they're like all right i just got a
brand new uh tarantula this thing could
kill me in an instant but my god she's a
beauty you know like it's just
so happy to see this like really to be
fair a lot of venomous creatures do look
[ __ ] cool yeah would i want to be
around one though that's your life
insurance no uh does your life insurance
cost go up if you own like a venomous
spider or a snake you might have to give
maybe like double vaccination you know
like double
like double life insurance
it's like can i can i like double what
i'm sure
like the delta strain of like the cobra
wouldn't it be so cool if like and like
you know uh anti-venom just like work
like that or you know antidotes for
venomous poison it just works like yeah
let me see
can i get the cobra
even if you did you wouldn't get it
because like why would you why would any
normal person need like 100 different
[ __ ] snake
uh infection venom i don't [ __ ] know
what are we doing we're not [ __ ]
killer from hunter hunter well you know
poison training no but like what if
you're like going to like a specific
like area of the world that has like
yeah they do it's like if you go to like
uh certain places that have like really
bad uh mosquitoes or something yeah you
get like right now
so why so why not like people who say
like you know decide like oh i'm gonna
go to the australian outback be like all
right just give me like i don't think
it's that much of a concern well yeah i
feel like i think i feel like you've
seen you hear about people dying i feel
like you have more chance of getting hit
in like by a car in the airport than you
do from getting so i feel like we should
ban cars before we sydney airport
that place is a [ __ ] mess it feels
like the dumbest superpower anyone could
hope for yeah
it's just like that one guy in like
mayhew academy who has quirks against
like every anti-venom and he's only
useful in australia like everywhere and
else in the world he's just useless he's
like born in the uk he's like what [ __ ]
i can't use this at
though it just takes all [ __ ] long
time yeah exactly yeah yeah i mean you
can like you can build up some
resistances to like some venoms i don't
know how much you can build up
resistance because i don't know if
there's been any studies of like anyone
who's like tried to build up enough
resistance like take on like a back
black cobra or something like that yeah
um but i don't think you'd need to yeah
it's like alcohol isn't it you just get
more used to it
but it's it's like that's uh
the more you get bitten the more
resistant
i assume if there is like uh something
that
makes i don't know like there's those
ants or something that like make you
really in pain maybe if you just like
what aunt specific like
like like the bullet what if you got
bitten by one every single day surely
after a while is you wouldn't phase you
after like ten years maybe she wants to
try this
well no because like i'm experimenting
well we want to be bitten by [ __ ]
every day for the next day isn't there
that tribe that is like revolved around
putting a glove of bullet hands on your
i'm pretty sure it's like a
thing that they do during ceremonies
it's like to initiate like a kid into ch
adulthood
yeah yeah yeah but like from what i can
understand like the people in the tribe
are more resistant to that venom than
other people who have tried it oh yeah
obviously yeah so i mean i don't know
why they like who who decided that
who decided that they would do that as a
ceremony you know what let's just get a
bunch of [ __ ] answers thing you yeah
you're a man now i want to hear like the
the council meeting of like when they
decided that they were like all right so
so jim's just turned 18 you know he's
he's been he's ready to bear children
he's ready to be a dad um yeah but we
need like a ceremonious thing some guy's
like
maybe just share a beer with him it's
like yeah that's kind of like what if we
though
hear me out
put his hands
into a fire ant nest
genius i probably gets it i'm i
understand why i mean you know i'm not
here to be like wow
know
the only difference is that we just
agree you talk about like astrology yeah
yeah yeah i'm joking
you're like oh i'm gonna get married
tomorrow apparently yeah oh
i thought i thought i was just like i
don't think angry is a star no no no you
could be angry right from the start
i gotta put the [ __ ] snake glove on
yeah yeah like i you know they probably
thought that it had some meaning and it
and it probably carries some value of
course like i'm sure right here's the
thing we know that like jumping in a
cold
bath or something is good for you yeah
we know that because of science like
showers but before if there was no
science backing this up and you were
like connor jump in the math for some
for health reasons i'm like [ __ ] off i'm
not jumping on a cold back why would i
jump in a cold bear i'm not doing that
it's stupid i mean why would that help
me i wouldn't do it even if i knew those
whole threesomes but like it's like you
know now that there is right and so i
can understand why maybe these people
have this notion that like i'm sure
there might even be health benefits to
getting bitten by our heads i don't know
maybe there is we haven't we just
haven't researched it there's so many
things that haven't been researched we
don't know i don't i don't think this is
worth researching personally what if i
told you that like if you like you know
uh inflated your uh your big toe once a
year would help with curing alzheimer's
you're probably like well [ __ ] i'm not
gonna do that but thanks
you know what i mean there's so many
things that can help ex disease or help
stop things right
i'm just not going to do that well like
when they're like that one paper came
out that one time that was like research
suggests eating no more than five french
fries at a time to lower the risk of
cancer it's like let's be honest i'm
never gonna eat less than five french
fries that's just impractical i'm just
not gonna
i think like at the end of the day
people just don't care
like if they couldn't convince smokers
to stop smoking by like actual
scientific research that proved that it
heavily increases your chance to get
cancer the more you smoke you know if if
they couldn't convince humanity to stop
smoking after that then
then what would like five french fries
like
five like eating less than five french
fries because like the moment you're
like oh yeah you should probably stop
smoking because you know it could give
you every type of lung cancer or you
know just cancer in general there's just
like
a cool life i think that's it but as
humans like we're so [ __ ] at uh
recognizing
long-term effects and by long-term in
like more than like a week yeah like
something in fact we just don't think
it'll affect us yeah because it's like
oh it's a week away anything could
happen
tomorrow we just we just ignore the fact
that bad stuff can happen to us by doing
it yeah but yet isn't it so weird that
there's such like a a disposition
between people who are like that where
they're like oh it's happening in like
three days from now that's basically
never going to happen to people who you
know say believe in things like
astrology where they're like oh in 73 in
years and four days time i'm going to
get hit by a car well [ __ ] i better stop
preparing
you
you know like those kinds of like space
like systems right like you know not to
like you know not to throw anyone's
belief system under the bus you can
believe whatever the [ __ ] you want right
but like that was one thing i always had
trouble
you know coming to terms with with that
kind of stuff right where it's like it's
so up in the air that it really and it's
not backed up by science in any way as
of right now that it's like
you know how why would you even think
about something like that whereas like
with smoking for example it's like
well yeah um
i had like seven of my [ __ ] grant you
know friends granddads died because of
lung cancer probably due to smoking so
you should you know if that doesn't
convince you
yeah i mean i guess i guess it comes
down to the point where like it's it's
like even now science
as sad as it is science in the
in this day and age isn't always like
the determining factor over whether
people listen to uh listen to what
science says or not because nowadays
it's because science is the government
dude and you don't want to trust the
government well i think science the
problem is with science and you know the
this age of like misinformation and just
not knowing what one is one is a lot of
misinformation out there not knowing
which sources to trust and number two
science has just got so advanced that
the normal person isn't going to be able
to follow along with what science says
because the logic is so past what a
normal person would be able to
understand that you might as well be
talking about god or [ __ ] or [ __ ]
stars in the sky because like you know
how am i gonna understand what the [ __ ]
scientists are researching when it comes
to like making mini black holes in the
cern like institute or whatever like and
they're like [ __ ] firing protons at
each other like yeah the [ __ ] do i know
about that yeah you know you know what i
mean that's that's so fuc they're so far
beyond my knowledge of understanding
just sounds like science fiction it
literally sounds like science fiction
unfortunately we're a sucker for a good
answer and an easy solution yeah so
especially when like you know the top
researchers and scientists in the world
are like you know when explaining like
how does gravity work and they're just
like we don't know then they're like ha
i told you must be jesus yeah you know
like just like because we hate it when
we don't know something
like no matter how significant or
insignificant it is and so when
immediately when we're thrown into that
kind of situation humans are just very
good to being like well it's magic
must be magic a lot of times we just
garner towards what feels right or what
we want to believe you know it's like we
like to believe that we're all like
unbiased robots who only go with pure
facts and logic but a lot of the times
we are very biased towards our beliefs
and it takes
i guess i guess it takes a lot more
effort to unbelieve and unlearn
something than it is to just you know
than it is to
um
learn something fresh or just like build
up your beliefs fresh well i'm sure that
happens in like between scientists as
well right like as much as you think
scientists are just like purely like
facts and logic based only no emotion
thrown into whatsoever i'm sure you know
there's been instances where like a
scientist or you know let's say like a
physicist like comes up and be like all
right i've got this new theory yeah
about how the universe was created what
do you think here's here's a bunch of
theoretical things that you know we've
been researching all that kind of stuff
i'm sure there's been a couple of
scientists who are like
no yeah that sounds dumb as [ __ ] because
i don't like you yeah
that happens a lot right and you know a
lot of scientists are also religious a
lot of them you know because there's a
lot of
we don't know
a lot of things and also science isn't
about
um having concrete answers it's about
attempting and trying everything and
then proving that there's no other way
yeah it could be anything else right i
think that's the problem is that a lot
of people have this rigid view of
science is like it can only be
science is a hundred percent right all
the time and it's not we're just
eliminating things that we know for sure
it isn't yeah yeah and so a lot of the
time when theories are uh presented or
hypotheses or whatever you know we have
so so many examples of history being
incorrect and yeah we fix it when we
realize it and the problem is is that
a lot of the time
that kind of gets galvanized into being
like all right well look science is
wrong sometimes i get it wrong and it's
like no we never science is never ever
presented to know everything it's we're
building the most it's the most accurate
representation that we have at this
current time we're building up a library
of what we think i think i think like
tim mentioned said it the best way he
said like science adjusts its views
based on what's observed yeah and faith
is the denial of observation so that
belief can be preserved yeah and i'm
like that's pretty much it because it's
like science as you said like science
changes all the [ __ ] time because we
don't know everything in the world right
so it's like so we have to kind of make
compromises for what we now know which
could completely change what you know
like say like 500 years ago when people
legitimately believed that like the sun
rotates around the earth and not the
other way around and then when they
discovered that they were like well [ __ ]
all these sites what have all these
science has been doing for the past 500
years wasting our time the problem is
that we're really bad as like humans of
understanding
stuff we don't know yeah uh you know
because if you'd have back then it would
make total sense that we the sun
revolves around ours because it looks
like it does and yeah we
don't have any other way of even
remotely comprehending that it couldn't
revolve around us
but once you find out it's like oh well
of course of course of course we revolve
around it yeah that makes so much sense
yeah so it's really easy to
believe in the the thing that you your
makes sense that makes most like logical
sense in your brain because like yeah
like i said like i said before like
science now has got to a point where a
lot of the more advanced concepts uh
where the normal person is not going to
be able to comprehend and so at that
point you're going to have your just
putting your faith in a person of
authority that their understanding is
good enough that they can you know take
what these studies say and present that
in a manner which you can understand but
at the end of the day you're still
putting a trust your trust into
something that you don't fully
understand yourself
which uh i mean getting back to the
getting back to like the habits and the
things you uh believed even if you know
science is like disproved there like do
you guys have like any like wives tales
or like anything that any habits that
was formed from basically at a childhood
age where like your parents said
something oh yeah and you like you you
did it as a kid because you your mum or
dad said so dude dude i have a japanese
grandma they are nothing but wife
like okay so like to this day like
whenever i get ill right
i eat a [ __ ] ton of oranges right like i
eat like a pack of oranges oranges
and like because because when i was
young um my mom said oh vitamin c is
good for the immune system uh when it's
comfortable i don't know where that came
from i'm pretty sure there is some
science back to it but like i think i've
read into it once and yes vitamin c does
improve the immune system but that's
like one i believe okay this is this is
all my memory so you know feel please
fact check this
it also might have just been god's
health it might it might have just been
my my household but one i believe that's
to like
like prevent illness so it like boosts
your immune system so it's more a more
healthy immune system and two there's
only so much
vitamin c intake you can uh you can you
can do to really have a big effect on
your immune system so but like that
doesn't matter in my mind because in my
mind i'm like i've been conditioned to
think i am ill i need to eat a [ __ ] ton
of oranges to in take this vitamin c
to have these [ __ ] basically just
like a pavlovian i think yeah yeah yeah
right right it's like it coughs once
where are the oranges
that's so weird because in my house it
was if you were starting to get sick or
you were sick my mom and my granddad my
grandma especially my grandma would make
me eat a shitload of ginger and spring
onion
i don't know why
um it just it just seems like a healthy
alternative but yeah it's just one of
those things where it has that taste to
it that you're like this has to be
helpful
i don't know why but this has to be
because it's causation
it's because it tastes like medicine
yeah like it tastes like medicine before
even like being put in a dish you know
yeah another one i had a lot was uh like
if i got like a cut on like my knee or
something yeah uh then you'd uh my
grandma would tell me to put wasabi on
it what what the [ __ ]
that's a very famous japanese one though
a lot of a lot of uh what that's a very
famous where did that come from i don't
know maybe it's because like you know
when you put like an antiseptic on right
and it starts to sting yeah but that
means it's like killing the bacteria
right so someone probably thought well
wasabi does that regularly is that where
the stinging kind of thing i think the
singing is part of killing bacteria i
think she's like no
i don't know if that's even a lifestyle
either but like i did i did like when i
was little like you know i i was running
around in the park and then i [ __ ]
slid and scratched my knee and you know
it was fine until i got home and my
grandma grandmother was like oh [ __ ] we
gotta patch you up dog so then she went
into the kitchen and i was like uh the
bandages are over here she's like no no
no i got this
pulls out a [ __ ] chewable wasabi and
i was like
grandmother what are you doing oh no no
no no no and she's like all right just
just hold still
[ __ ] pulls you know squirt someone to
a finger and just starts like rubbing my
knee oh and uh
that [ __ ] hurts
no [ __ ] like a lot and uh
you know
i wouldn't exactly say it worked um if
anything it just added an extra step of
oh now it hurts and i have to shower
and it burns now and it burns my my
regular skin that's not affected by the
cut
yeah so that was the moment i was like
grandma you should probably like you
know
read up on like some you know basic
first aid i'm just wondering where that
started from because like i can imagine
it's something similar to like putting
salt on a wound right which is you know
it's uh it sterilizes the wounds uh
as well as it could as well as it could
do does it i thought it was just painful
no it does i think we google this i
don't know by the
way somewhat anti-bacterial okay yeah
but if i pissed on your leg it'd be
somewhat hand-tied back to you the
problem is that this is the problem when
you when when these things get some form
of like it's like yeah you're one
percent right one percent right
right i heard right i heard right i
better add that to my five-minute daily
life
yeah is is salt uh like a like a kind of
like an anticipated supposedly it
creates conditions that make it
difficult for bacteria to grow
supposedly written by the same person
you did that because you want to like
be painful like you would torture
someone what
what do you mean well you think it's
like people in the painting that's why
we say salt on the wound because it's
like all right let's say i [ __ ] you
over to put salt in the wound i'll do it
to [ __ ] someone over it it is painful
but i'm pretty sure where do they
originate from salt on the wound can you
google this i'm pretty sure it's not
meant it's not medical already it's like
it's to add more pain to it i mean i
think it came from like salt is like a
preserver right so it kind of makes it
hard for bacteria to grow it preserves
the wound
this is complete [ __ ] you're making
this up now okay actually i don't know
where i know this from [ __ ] the idiom
means what you
[Music]
is is it so
does putting salt in a wound make it
worse at all does it do anything doesn't
make it hurt more yeah i know that i
know that
i know that more but it's also like you
know it makes it difficult with bacteria
because it does that yeah it makes it
difficult it's so vague though that's
like there's a different scene of
treatment and something yeah just put
some antiseptic on it sure if i cut my
leg off it'd be harder for me to walk
like i'm you know it's put some just put
some salt
that's why like you wash wounds with
like saline solution as well yeah you
don't do it with salt
yeah but sailing solution is salt water
yeah it's salt water that's if you don't
put like you're not putting on those
like the [ __ ] rocks rubbing it in
there we're done
that's not what i said
the saying isn't put saline on them
if i'm like lost in the wilderness or
something and i'm like fight like
[ __ ] miles away from
some rocks yeah just just like just like
right
now
and just like just
sprinkle it on sprinkle japan japan
though is full of so many of those kinds
of idioms taking medical advice from
idioms oh no no no
but like there's a lot of like idioms
like that especially in japan where it's
like you know one of them that my
grandma used to tell me all the [ __ ]
time was like don't whistle at night
because snakes will come yeah and it
wasn't until a couple years later i
found out snakes are deaf so
yeah and then i started whistling like a
[ __ ] during the night time you
know so it's like where do they come
from i don't know it's like uh yeah like
i said step on the crack break your
break your mother's back why okay i i
and as a kid i even i i was when i'd
heard this i was like no
that doesn't make any sense how fragile
is my mother's dark i was like i've
stepped on many cracks
intentionally after hearing this to test
the theory out um would am i a bad
person probably if you go home you're
most like riding on the ground oh no no
no
no
everyone has collectively stepped on a
crack at some point isn't the earth just
one big crack that's it's just it's all
one big tectonic plate also what old
japan is a crown also what defines as a
crack like if i were to step on an ass
crack would i still break my mother's
back off
i'm pretty sure
for a second
how how amazing how this uh you know
scientific fact actually just rhymes as
well yeah wow
also uh but other stuff that i don't
really believe in anything like that and
even as a kid i remember that whenever i
heard these i was like no that doesn't
sound right why what like a cat crossing
under an uh going under a ladder oh yeah
or a black cat crossing your path is bad
i think that's more like superstition
though that's a superstition yeah that's
what is this is
chugging a bunch of oranges not
superstition
i guess sorry it is they're all
superstitions i don't know if wait what
is it what's the difference
what's the difference between a
superstition in an idiom
say um uh well idioms are more to
explain like it's
like an example uh raining cats and dogs
but oh yeah so yeah all of these okay
replace eating with soups yeah yeah yeah
these are all superstitions so you know
i i guess it's superstitious of you to
consume a bunch of oranges in the hope
that it will cure your illness right
that's superstitious i feel like there's
no other word you have no no because
it's it's
cause it's purely based on like
hearsay and information you've heard and
stuff yeah but but i feel like this
yeah it's so superstitious though right
that's what it originates from it's all
underneath that right
it's come from like someone's experience
that has been passed down superstition
feels more like supernatural right where
you know like uh like opening up your
umbrella ins indoors is good it's bad
luck i don't know where that came from
but like at least like i don't do that
anyway because why would you do that
yeah yeah yeah you're opening indoors oh
like what if you're in like an umbrella
store and you want to test it out right
yeah they have umbrella stores
yeah in japan you never get to open it
though do you yeah you know what yeah
yeah i mean
i'm cracking that bad boy okay i cracked
that bad boy that's you know come on i
found my own house and then every
middle-aged woman in that store looked
at me like superstition
i don't know
in japan though a lot of people do do
they really yeah a lot of people do i
feel like in asia the culture around
superstition is like very very prevalent
because everything everything is
superstitious
it has some kind of merit to it well
because everything like you know because
the whole belief system is very like
spiritual based right so i think a lot
of superstitions are more widely
believed there's like a i'd say a scale
of like yeah stepping on a crack or
break your mind yeah yeah that's like
that's the lower end of body yeah yeah
yeah whereas maybe i've heard this from
many people the vitamin c thing yeah
yeah which i i don't know if there's any
merit i don't know if it does i don't
know it's just like there is some like
really really basic logic around it that
you're like i can kind of see that it's
like saying like it's like i have this
theory that drinking water
will help me feel better and it's like
you're right but i feel like you're
vastly
like over simple it's kind of like the
same thing with say you you like your
experience with like manuka honey right
i'm just like yeah that is superstitious
yeah yeah yeah
i'm just like is there any science
behind that but like when i had when i
had covered i was like [ __ ] spooning
these this manuka honey like nobody's
business it actually like helped my
throat
it felt it felt a lot better
what's it called what's called uh the uh
placebo yeah that's like a placebo it
could be which is like i'd argue is a
branch of the superstitious tree because
that's different
placebo is the documented effect that it
actually has an effect yes yes
your your brain is
making up for some form of [ __ ] thing
that you think placebo is so interesting
because it's like it hasn't been like
properly studied and a lot of scientists
reckon and like a lot of psychologists
reckon there is like something
legitimate there but we just don't know
what it is because we we don't we don't
know the [ __ ] because it's like we don't
know if it's actually a thing that works
or if it's just coincidence yeah like
what the placebo effect is that it does
work we just don't know how yeah we
don't we don't know how talking about
it's like the whole um remember the uh
life flashing before your eyes thing
yeah yeah yeah and how i was telling you
guys recently there was an article that
said they were scanning someone's brain
on on a table we're just collecting
scans we didn't talk about this podcast
in the taxi i remember this oh yeah
the superstitious we mentioned that in
the episode before i knew that but joey
didn't go on it for too long so i was
like i won't say anything anyway
the guy was getting a scan a brain scan
right and
you know he's having a regular scanned
brain checking what's going on the brain
oh what's going on there and during this
generic scan that they were doing the
guy died of a heart attack and whilst
they were scanning him
while he was dying i assume they try to
help him actually they're just leaving
like now hold on let's just get him oh
this date is hold on hold on
um they did find out that apparently
right before he died it was the part of
his brain that was responsible for
memories was like firing like crazy yeah
which would although not proven because
it's only one instance it would back up
the theory that
your life
before your eyes at least all these
memories start flashing right yeah which
is makes which is one of those things
where it's like okay
i guess that makes sense because a lot
of people have said that it's happened
and yeah although there's no way to
solidly prove it but that's that's
until then it was
not superstitious we only have yeah we
only have testimonies from people who
have been like near-death experiences
yeah right right like you know and then
we have some kind of not 100 proof but
some evidence to indicate that the
theory holds more well yeah yeah yeah
it's uh we can kill people
right now basically like right before
they just like plug them out they just
feel like quick get on the cat's game
right now edge more
where they literally edged their life
at the whole thing oh that was that was
um
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i never saw that one that just sounded
like a dumb horror movie but not like
yeah i mean like
i wake up and i just saw jesus this
video is sponsored by rage shadow
legends did you know gentlemen rage
shadow legends is a free to play mobile
rpg game that has taken the world by
storm didn't know that joey tell me more
well i'll tell you more because the game
is available on pc and mobile with over
600 champions to choose from each with a
unique history in the world of talaria
here victory awaits those who can rally
the right champions these guys look
really cool you can see just how much
each orc is influenced by its tribe and
personality in each design here's a
couple of my favorites krila which arm
is one of the best ally attacker
champions in the game damn or this guy
robar well boys there's seriously never
been a better time to get started and if
you use our link or scan the qr code on
screen right now new players will get a
free starter pack worth almost thirty
dollars to keep starting your game
dollars thirty dollars and we're talking
right we're talking a free champion item
200 000 silver one xp boost one energy
refill and the one ancient shot so you
can summon an awesome champion as soon
as you get involved
you will find these rewards here in your
inbox for the next 30 days only
back to the episode going back to like
the salt thing and uh just you're not
you're not gonna let this guarantee no
because because
just like talking about it just reminded
me about uh the time where i kind of got
an ulcer i believe and so like have you
you've had a mouth also before right so
how do you deal with it i put like ulcer
cream on it okay what do what if you
don't have ulcer cream like what did i
just don't try not to touch it
toothpaste toothpaste i thought
toothpaste works is that a suggestion
okay so like as a kid my mom was just
like oh just gargle salt water or like i
believe
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry damn it
sorry i was like
i was i was legitimately right about to
say when you said i was like [ __ ]
how do we go from saltwater to diesel we
have a million
yeah i would either like gargle
salt water or mouthwash and then one day
my ulcer was like so bad
that uh the salt water wasn't doing
anything right yeah so like as like a
teenager i'm just like what if uh what
if uh instead of just doing salt water
which is basically just diluted salt
what if i just go straight to the sauce
and there's just [ __ ] pour salt on it
right and
uh that i swear to god that's uh so
that's what i did i i i just i just like
got some like salt and just poured it
all all over this ulcer and it's [ __ ]
it's standing like nobody's [ __ ] bro
it sounds like it's not like [ __ ]
hell
like burnt over in my mouth but then it
kind of numbs the wounds and i remember
waking up the next day and it was a lot
less painful it started healing straight
away now i don't know if there's any
science behind this i have googled it
and i know like some other people do it
as well but there's no like i don't know
if there's any back science behind it
but like after that i started putting
salt on my ulcer whenever i get a mouth
water and it seemed to like
it seemed to heal it i'm sure there is
like some kind of science behind it but
like i feel that's like
probably the more extreme method of
things like you basically just napalmed
your mouth yeah the science says you're
completely wrong yeah yeah it could be
good so i remember one could also just
be a coincidence
yeah one day connor just come into the
office and complaining about a mouth
ulcer and i was like i have the perfect
solution just walks into the kitchen
just pour a bunch of salt on it it's
it's easy i do it all the time do it all
the time i remember coming in him coming
in like the next day or something and he
was like gone why did you you literally
just convinced me to pour salt in a
wound that's all you've done didn't help
any it didn't i remember it didn't help
at all really just like it stopped the
pain for like two hours
in exchange for like one burst of
immense pain yeah but like it didn't do
anything you basically just pre-ordered
i think that gaunt would have healed
naturally without the soul and i think
he just poured saul and happens to
remember that it then went away
basically just didn't like ulcer
hardcore
illnesses that go away yeah right like
you know obviously in very serious
illnesses the pseudoscience is uh very
harmful yeah and very [ __ ] up that
people try and sell solutions that are
like you know they'll be like just take
our herbs and your cancer will go away
yeah like that's [ __ ] up yeah you're
even telling people yes but
i think the reason why with generic
illnesses so many superstitions come
about is because they go anyway on their
own and if you're doing [ __ ] and it
happens to go away you're probably your
mind is aha i was sick one time and then
i i i played with my poop for 20 minutes
in my hands like play-doh and it went
away the next day and it's like well no
that's
there
now i've got three other illnesses yeah
you can do things
anything yeah do it every single time
you get sick with a generic illness that
will go away anyway after 48 hours yeah
and then you'll remember that you did
that thing and then it went away yeah so
this probably happened with like the
vitamin c you probably maybe have a
little bit of placebo effect as well and
then boom it goes away and you're like
well it must be vitamin c because every
time i take vitamin c my cold goes as if
if you did nothing your vitamin c
wouldn't go away but it it's not how it
works it would go away anyway but i want
like an experiment of like especially
with the vitamin c thing of like catch a
cold one time do the vitamin c thing and
then catch a cold a second time and
don't do the vitamin c thing which one
you'll see you need to do this like a
hundred times to get any data worth
considering well there's plenty of sick
people today
you'd need the same person over and over
yeah even then it wouldn't matter
because we could just like view the
immune system anyway with the things
that we do we're gonna dedicate my whole
life to see if oranges work during the
flow
turns out we don't know yeah science
sucks because science is boring as [ __ ]
it takes a long time and people don't
like that yeah
unfortunately maybe we can make it they
want results now yeah of course it's
like yeah maybe we can we can go to
another planet in 200 years it's like oh
[ __ ] i'm not going to be around for that
so yeah
that's the problem back back to humans
are just so incapable of like really
caring about things that happen in like
the far future and like overwhelming
yeah
that's the reason why we're so [ __ ] with
it
it's not gonna affect me tomorrow so
that's [ __ ] whatever yeah i mean like
i mean we've talked about something
similar before where like talking about
just imagining five years in the future
or like where you're going to be five
years or ten years in the future can you
imagine what 2027 is going to be like no
yeah because everyone thought in 2012
that 2022 was like yeah flying cars i
couldn't imagine being 30 and here i am
for 31. like how the [ __ ] did that
happen you know i basically did i'm
basically dead
i think same with that exercise right
like i can't i i know exercise is good
for me yeah and i like it when i do it
yeah but i just can't
i can't visualize the benefits to my
life exactly
that's why it's so hard to maintain yeah
that's why it's so hard to keep it up
even though i feel amazing when i do it
i normally have so much energy i feel
great i know and i can feel the
immediate tangible benefits yeah but for
some reason i just can't convince myself
long term that i can visualize that hey
when i'm 70 maybe i'll be a lot better
off for it if i just put in the work now
even not even that it's just like you
know you could be like yeah you could be
like working out right and like a week
later you'd look down your body and be
like why do i still look exactly the
same that yeah that's nice as well dude
like it's it blows you get that pump on
you you go hard and you're like why why
but then you eat like two weeks of
mcdonald's and you're like wow nothing
changed amazing which you love it you
love that nothing changes but then you
get angry when it doesn't change
we suck as humans i know yeah that's
that's what sucks right is that if if
you want to gain weight fast oh look get
get ripped fast you also have to accept
the fact that maybe one binge drinking
weekend yeah [ __ ] your body to death
speaking of human sucking i uh i saw
this recent thing okay uh that uh
what a segway i mean because i i looked
at this and i thought oh my god humans
suck but there was an article that came
out uh not too long ago i'll just write
yahoo who by who's the article first uh
there's a lot of different articles that
came out uh all over the place but uh
i'll just read the i'll just read the
title of this article because it
explains everything go for it lonely ape
has just launched a dating app for nft
collectors a dating app a dating app
somebody has developed a dating app
specifically for nft bros
to date nft hoes
i don't i i think the problem with this
is is that everything there is or
everything
but let's now let's i'm going to take a
second okay what do you reckon the
demographic of people who have nfts are
okay okay
okay okay jojo esque dating app it's
gonna work no no no no no let's look at
this positively okay
so what you're saying is we're going to
be removing people with nft profiles
from our dating pool
i think i think that's the positive
right surely surely
but that means that we're just like
forcing these kinds of people to
reproduce
should not be allowed to reproduce no
i'm not saying that but you know
you're implying
well that's okay they they go on the
metaverse it's fine just like just like
reading through this article just made
me have like several aneurysms uh there
is no need to enter uh or display
personal information instead one can
link their crypto wallet to access the
app
once logged in the user can display
their net worth and nft pro portfolio
what you can also filter your matches by
their cryptocurrency value and the nft
collection
if i had a dollar for every time i saw
an article about something to do with
nfts that i despised i wouldn't need to
buy anything everywhere i was like why
didn't you probably own it
i've not seen a single good thing with
an article it's never like nft owners
pledge to uh stop global warming to save
the world and it's like no it's like nft
owners pledge to have a yacht club where
they all wank each other off or
something that's all it ever is it's
like the uh the nft restaurant thing
it's like
it's are you just making uh
are you just trying to make some kind of
tangible effect that you own an nft it's
like
there's some reason there's some reason
wait so so explain what this restaurant
you need to own an nft to go into the
restaurant yeah
that's it that's it that's it that's it
it's like so you just like you just go
up to the bounce and you'll be like
i mean
it's getting to the point where it's
just like classism with extra steps now
actually it's not even any extra steps
it's just
we've hated on fts like so many times i
i just yeah it sucks it sucks yeah i
just i just saw that going on i'm like i
i legitimately thought it was an onion
article at first because yeah it sounds
like one yeah i realized oh the sad
reality that's a real thing even if they
you know they could turn around and when
people back onto nfts which i don't
think they can
i i just can't see them
winning the public faith back in it
again now yeah since everyone has just
seen how much of a mess it's been i
don't you know and whatever you think
about the technology or whatever you
think about what it can be done with it
you have to recognize that the the nft
like this kind of landscape that it had
has become right now yeah such a mess
ripe with scams [ __ ] up [ __ ] money
laundering just every kind of awful
thing you can imagine yeah it has had
such a bad public wrap that it would not
only need to come up with something
revolutionary that is actually good it
would then have to win people back over
by fixing its image which i don't think
it can because the internet doesn't want
to to make it more regulated it doesn't
want to make it more it also just they
like how free it is yeah it also just
seems like that community doesn't really
care about it either no they do they do
do they yeah because they push it on to
everyone and everything well then how
come they're not how come they're not
trying to do anything to better their
image and instead make these [ __ ]
dating apps and restaurants it's a
free-for-all right now every company and
every person is trying to grab a part of
like it's a gold rush right everyone
wants that bit of it yeah so the reason
why everyone is shoving it down
everyone's throat is because they they
have investments they want to make sure
they don't lose their money okay onto
the next sucker who comes in too late
yeah and it's like it's it's also so
weird did you see the clip where it was
like think i think jimmy fallon like
presenting his nft with paris hilton
like
huh oh of course yeah yeah it's it's uh
is it a meme at least or is it like no
no no it is serious okay so
i believe i believe it's jimmy fallon
but uh jimmy fallon and paris hilton uh
well paris hilton was on the jimmy
fallon show and they started talking
about nfts and how paris hilton
convinced jimmy fallon to buy a broad
ape nft what a nice scenario
it's so it was so weird because it's
like i've never seen a clip of two
people more out of touch
with like the wider world so they they
like like so jimmy finally brings out
his like he's like bored but it's bought
april that's the name yeah yeah he
brings out yeah the monkeys yeah he
brings out
and he goes isn't this beautiful look at
this it's amazing and like you can hear
the audience clapping i've seen this
image i thought it was a meme really no
no no it is a real image on the picture
yeah and i've i've never heard such a
applause where it was so obvious that
there was a big light saying applause
please because you could tell the
audience had no idea what the [ __ ] they
were talking about
another massive problem with the whole
nft landscape right is that it benefits
the people who have big platforms right
if you have a big platform it's free
money for you that's why people are
doing this
the moment something is advertised to
you as you should buy it is the moment
it's too late for you anything
you know the moment that consumers are
seeing big names promoting it it's too
late to make money yeah some people
might make money the majority of people
are not going to make money no and the
majority of people are going to lose
money and the people who get money are
people like jimmy fallon people like uh
people already range
people who have the platform the power
to push people towards their investment
it's it's a glorified pyramid scheme in
many ways right because it's like how do
you get your money by getting more
people into it yeah right it's it's
that's how it works and that's why
you're seeing like when i tweet anything
or men or or mentioned in anything nft
it doesn't matter what the comment is
these these verified nft accounts like
everything with the with the phrase nft
in it yeah they don't i could be saying
nfts suck and they can gargle on my nuts
and and someone who supports nft will
like that comment just because they've
googled nft and they like everything
because they're trying to get followers
they're trying to get engagement so then
they can push it more and have more
biggest fear of influence what if they
just like gargling or nuts they might
call themselves they probably probably
do yeah they do yes please
i hate it i hate it so much because it's
so
obviously a scam like the moment that
you are being
advertised to about buying an investment
is the moment that you've you've already
you can't make money and i think that's
what's so [ __ ] disappointing as well
especially with you know as you said
like big influences right like getting
in on it like [ __ ] you know when i
when i saw that like eminem bought like
an nft of just what looks like a monkey
version of himself i was like why would
you do that
because never before every childhood
you have a big sphere of influence it's
just free money exactly and in their
eyes it's low risk public image because
you're not asking your
you don't have to it's not like you're
begging your followers for money but
what you're doing is making them pay for
something yeah that makes your thing
more valuable it's heavy incentivizing
right and and you can claim
just that you it's just an investment
it's like buying a stock it's not like
buying a house it's not like buying a
stock it's different right there's rules
around buying for reasons right yeah
even though
sometimes the rules are a bit [ __ ]
yeah still
yeah i mean like passionately about this
and i i hate the system so much well i'm
like the the only thing i have to add to
this is like do you think this negative
image is purely you know it's purely
based on like the western circle and
just like our perception of the internet
definitely because because like i've
heard like of like nfts have a very very
different perception in like the
japanese circles and uh
and you know the japanese especially the
art communities as well because they see
it as
from what i've read at least they've
they they have a much more positive view
of nfts and they see it as like an
opportunity to of course give uh you
know ownership to artists and stuff like
that which is a lot you know given the
cultures i understand why maybe japanese
people would be more
more accepting of this idea because it's
it's like for japanese people and
japanese artists it's a lot bigger
problem than it is
i'm awful giving rights to artists and
whatnot but you know i feel there are
other ways that you can do it if the
systems were you know properly
implemented not to mention that in japan
like you know the the whole copyright
laws in japan especially are just like
on the next level of outdated yeah right
like it's so like i think if anything
the reason why japanese are gonna yeah
of course of course the japanese are
gonna look at nfts and things like oh
this is perfect like this this gets
around everything that we've believed in
and done in like a really cool way that
supports artists like more more ways to
copyright [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah bring it
in yeah yes please that requires the
good faith of
all parties involved though yeah like
everyone has to be using it correctly
yeah yeah and the problem is is that
they're not english we're definitely not
you know and there is there's some very
valid reasons to to own nfts or bitcoin
or any any of these currencies right
like if you live in a
if you're like a russian person right
now and all your money was in the ruble
yeah you're [ __ ] yeah like your
money's gone yeah you just don't you
don't own much money anymore if you had
that all in a bitcoin wallet yeah you'd
still be very wealthy right so that
makes more that in those scenarios it
makes a lot of sense problem is it's
kind of replicated
what the fine art world was before
to like the big private investors right
it was basically fine art it was this
glorified
money
money laundering and money
transactioning thing right yeah and now
in the west people figured out huh
you can make a lot of money and money
that you can hide very easily
by doing this nft [ __ ] and so it's kind
of turned into more of a democratized
fine art
yeah [ __ ] for people right like uh like
the whole uh you've watched like tenant
did you watch tennant yeah i watched
tenants you know like the art that was
held in the um
in the airports because it couldn't be
text that's actually real thing i know
that's a real thing was that a major
part of tenant that was a big uh plot
point and tenant is where they steal the
the they steal the artwork and all the
valuable stuff from the airport uh
holding uh the tax haven in the airport
clearly this movie really made an
impression on god
i just remember things going backwards
like that's like things looking cool
that's like the first time in like media
that i can recall that has like told
people that these things exist yeah yeah
people didn't know these existed before
um you know it's just was that a massive
part of tenon i feel like i would have
remembered that which scene which which
scene was this in was this in the first
scene i don't remember that i'm never
gonna know the full [ __ ] playlist of
ten and i don't know what [ __ ]
happened i just like they had a big
there was a big plot point about them
doing a heist
in the first half of the movie
was there oh my [ __ ] the only thing i
know is that the one's been wrong
he basically did oh my god
when he dies like his life doesn't flash
before his eyes just 10 at the movies
i remember them being in an airport but
i don't remember them
pulling another one
why were they in the airport
why they're in an
airport
maybe uh they were getting a flight or
something no they were investigating the
they were this is a complete [ __ ]
tangerine because they were going into
they were investigating the phenomena
right that uh that you know the
phenomena where time moves backwards or
something that's that's all i remember
ish i can't remember they're stealing
something they're just holding because
and in the holding places they normally
have art because you can't we could
basically buy and sell in this area
because it doesn't yeah yeah it's not
under any jurisdiction yeah yeah
taxpayer right so you can no i i
remember there being pain i remember the
paintings there i just don't know i just
don't remember that being like a massive
part of the plot point but
it was just like it was like i brought
it up because it was like the first time
it had been addressed or like brought up
in like uh prominent media yeah um well
these things exist yeah well they've
existed for like a very very long time
and it's not just like fine arts but
like and like it's not just paintings
any valuable thing like after stuff in
the british museum
yeah that's normally the place where
they come from you know like
the point was is that it's
i just think with the way that nfts are
structured right now it's just this is
this was obviously going to happen yeah
it was it's just been ripe with scams
like half this [ __ ] is awful like yeah
there's some legitimate uses the
technology seems somewhat promising
right now the fact that it uses more
than like most countries the entire like
bitcoin network uses more electricity
than countries
is very concerning yes um
and that there are more you know they're
making new coins they're making new ways
that are much more efficient and stuff
yeah yeah we get it but it's not there
right now yeah it's not it's not doing
that right now it's not working right
now in a way that works for the world do
you think it will never work out yeah it
definitely will at some point obviously
the idea of having
a way that you can 100 own something
digitally is going to be very convenient
at some point yes
[Music]
yeah
right now it just doesn't the way that
it's being used is like a joke no i mean
like it's weird it's weird seeing how
fast they just came from like basically
nowhere to everyone talking about them i
mean crypto because it's been just so
like it's just been shoved down every
once in a while
yeah it was literally last year where i
had not heard of the word nft until like
may or april and then i couldn't stop
hearing it i was like i remember being
like i mean i only found out what it was
like a couple i'm on the [ __ ] podcast
podcast yeah yeah i'm i'm so envious of
you
because i i think i just like yeah i
just avoided all that [ __ ] i don't
follow anyone who is now there's the
metaverse that's coming along
well have you seen that these companies
are buying like space in like the
metaverse they're buying like plots of
land in the metaphase yeah yeah i've
seen that yeah so they're why they're
buying digital land yeah
dude that's like i mean i feel like it
is just that's some sci-fi territory i i
feel like the past year uh has opened up
basically the age of like the digital
gold rush is this what it must have felt
like to see like the dot-com bubble i
think i think i think so that's that's
that's must have been what it felt like
where you see millions of [ __ ]
dollars being invested in the dumbest
[ __ ] yeah yeah in like
fuckingkittens.com or something like i
don't [ __ ] know and now kittens.com
is worth millions yeah right i don't
know if this is true but you're in the
metaverse right they don't have legs
have you seen that no they don't have uh
they only have two like torsos this is
very much similar with me with nfts i
know nothing about the metaphors so do
do you know why sort art online by
facebook yeah yeah that's all i know do
you want to take a guess why they only
have torsos in this world why is it for
people who perhaps are in wheelchairs
and stuff like that or it's a very noble
thought yeah unfortunately it's not
maybe inclusive
you can fetch this actually but to my
understanding it was to stop people like
doing like implying sexual acts and
stuff and doing things
from what i understand from what i
understand that is the reason why i mean
it is like i read somewhere that like
foot fetishes are like i think the most
common fetish in like like the world
what's going to do with facebook
because of the legs but it's like
digital feet it's like yeah
i was just master chief i was like are
you going with this
features
them sims feet though
delicious why didn't they just delete
the feet then if they
just have no one for you
everyone just looks like kirby you know
just stubs and knobs apparently it's a
technical issue like the cameras can't
capture the whole body mm-hmm [ __ ]
i don't think is there anything
mentioned about sexual stuff
can you google sexual mark zuckerberg
metaverse no legs
so apparently uh as well there's like a
you have like your own bubble you can't
come into your space
but to me it's weird right because i
don't know if i'm just like stupid but
it just looks like
really [ __ ] vr chat that's what i saw
and i was like so is this like a game
that facebook is developing or just
looks like vr chat but just less fun and
uh like vr chat has really good games in
it have you seen this no there's like
games in vr chat and it's nuts i was
playing super monkey ball the other day
oh wow in vrc yeah vr chat how were you
not sick i don't know i guess and there
was also like i could sing playing
regular
like uh
like a tron game where you throw discs
and they bounce around you'll dodge it
that's pretty cool i hit the other
person it just seems like a vr game in a
vr game yeah so it is and there's like
there's a whole cooking game right in a
vr game and it's like free it's like why
the [ __ ] would anyone want how does vr
chat work i never because i've never
played vr chat but is it is it like kind
of like an open source kind of thing
where people can create
their own their own games and their own
spaces and stuff like that oh okay it's
all user generated okay that's why it's
so [ __ ] good it's like yeah yeah
because you'll be in a lobby and yeah
does it is it annoying that you get in
the lobby and there's like 10 year olds
screaming yeah that's annoying and i
think mark zuckerberg is trying to
address that by making it like age uh
only like i don't know over a certain
age allowed to join yeah
but vr is still really good like it's
it's genuinely good so okay so so going
back to the whole like buying digital
plots of land on on meta okay right like
how does that work
like what i don't know
the question of why well if you own
digital land it's it's like the
metaverse is being marketed as this
place that is kind of like just a new
virtual reality world that everyone's
going to go to right so you can
literally live like a second life or
even like you know your online media
life
in this virtual place that's called the
metaverse so what are companies doing
they're literally buying plots of land
in this virtual land for
treating it like they're blind they're
buying real lands that exists in the
real world
this is just lane this is
legitimately scary you want to hit like
the most depressing thing ever please
investors are playing paying millions
for virtual land in the metaverse
and um apparently uh
uh a company recently dropped 2.5
million dollars on a patch of land in
decentral land one of the most popular
metaverse worlds and the prices have
gone up 400 to 500 percent in the past
few months how much land are we talking
like how many digital how many digital
square meters are we talking i don't
fully understand it
another person uh spent 4.3 million on a
parcel of virtual land
oh my god um i
oh my god is this what happens when you
just have too much money yes i think
this is what i think what's happening is
that a lot of companies with a lot of
money are like let's just throw
something into it all right if it fails
it doesn't matter if it if it goes up
tenfold big money right yeah i think
that's what's going on and i think
people in companies are hearing whispers
of it and i think i i also imagine as
well that facebook is doing a really
good job at convincing these companies
oh yeah that that this is going to be a
big deal yeah when i feel like anyone
who is in the tech space
looks at metaverse and is like i just
don't see how this can become a thing
that's like good yeah
because how the [ __ ] are you going to
convince everyone
to get a virtual headset do you know how
annoying they are to i'm i love my tech
and i gotta admit virtual reality
headsets are a pain in the [ __ ] ass
yeah absolutely well it comes with the
uh assumption that
virtual reality headsets will be at one
point more streamlined than they already
are
um which they really really need to be
because like the barrier of entry for
our virtual headset is like [ __ ] done
great obviously yeah that is facebook
yeah and that that is probably the most
user-friendly headset yeah but it's
still like it's not perfect it's not
perfect
you don't want to have a business [ __ ] i
do not want to have a business meeting
without a [ __ ] headset on it's like
honey where's my headset i need to get
into business one of the main pictures
of like the metaverse like you could
have a a meeting with your co-workers
have you had a virtual reality headset
on for more than two hours no it is i
have it's awful it's it gets
sweaty it's like it's bulky the only
reason why i haven't done a stream on my
oculus is because i can't wear that
thing for more than 20 minutes without
feeling sick
that's what it also it also depends on
the game yeah because i remember like i
remember hearing about these rumors that
people get motion sickness from wearing
headsets yeah
superstitions
superstitions now i'm just [ __ ]
you're not sick and i'm just like they
must just be weak-minded i ain't like
that i remember like the first time i
got like my uh
valve index uh one of the first games i
bought was like uh pavlov i think right
it was like the it's like the basically
a virtual reality cs go okay yeah and i
remember
walking in that for like 10 seconds and
i just got immediate [ __ ]
motion sickness like like my brain
searched through like my the entire
history of humanity to like see if there
was any any kind of experience that
could like help regulate what i was
going through and it was just like yeah
nope i don't know what's going on right
now you're just gonna you're just gonna
feel sick right now
like the thing is i get motion sickness
even if it's like not a very like
movement intensive game like i get i get
sick after like 20 minutes of beat sable
yeah and like you you're not even
[ __ ] moving in that game yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm totally fine in the motion
sickness part yeah i've only had one
one game that's given me motion sickness
yeah or like my emotions like make me
feel like oh
yeah it was like this ninja game santiro
or something yeah like you jump around
it's pretty sick but like you you jump
in the air yeah really [ __ ] high yeah
you can change direction in the air
again in any direction oh so you can
imagine it's like jump up fly back and
it's it's yeah i'm getting sick just
hearing it um but it's good um but i the
thing that i have difficulty with is
these headsets are not light yeah
they're uh they are uncomfortable to
wear
yeah yeah yeah yeah the index i love the
index amazing great piece of hardware it
is heavy and also the wires can suck my
dick i hate the wires yeah um what i
like about the oculus there's no wires
yeah like the thing the thing is that i
can't play a virtual or i haven't been
able to play a virtual reality game more
than a few hours before either like my
head gets tired or i just want to chill
out and i just want to like because like
i start sweating a lot because you're
wearing i swear yeah yeah you you start
like
i mean like you were basically wearing a
sink on your head
it's not comfortable at all and like i i
don't
i don't think i don't know if this is
just like booming me talking but
i i can't see it being a real substitute
for just face-to-face interactions to me
at least no it won't i mean like you
know again like in order for the
metaverse thing to really pop off it
needs to be like vi headsets need to be
common enough in every household as much
as like say a computer is today right
and i just don't see it happening for a
while the oculus just isn't it isn't
quite there and it's also expensive
i think the oculus is 300 bucks yeah
yeah and yeah that's that's uh that's
that's steep for a lot of people yeah um
i think you know if you look at the the
the progress we've made in the past what
10 years when did the htc revive come
out that was the first big one wasn't
the first big yeah what was that when
did the htc vive get released nationally
you can even look htc what
i thought it was the oculus rift was the
first like real
big one that's the first one i heard was
that like the one that was with steam
yes that was that's the oculus rift that
was like the the og oculus rift that was
before facebook facebook with the mouse
yeah yeah htc vive was unveiled in march
2015. okay what about the oculus rift
the original yeah the original oculus
rift was along with the roller coasters
yeah yeah i thought the the htc vive was
the first time vr headsets became like
somewhat vulnerable like a thing like to
play games like seriously
watch 2016. oh okay
know i could be totally wrong i don't
you could google what the first vr heads
is
i think it's fair to say at least to my
memory at least
that i think the htc vive was the first
headset that came out that like made
gaming seem like it
made sense yeah on that on a it wasn't
just a gimmick it was like you could
actually play games like super hot was
amazing uh some of the demos are really
good and there were games coming out
here and there that were pretty good as
well yeah
no you know i think we thought there was
going to be a big boom
but it there really hasn't been it's
just many games in the past seven years
it's just because the money isn't there
right now because it's so hard
there's so many barriers of entry um for
buying like a vr game so like the only
big game i can think of is half-life
um that's that's the only like game
where i look at this vr game and it's
like stands up as like a game game you
know it's like a lot of games that i
play on on vr it seems like a tech demo
with like it seems like a glorified tech
demo but like half-life actually feels
like a game and that's because you know
valve like invested in it and i don't
even like i can't believe they made
profit on it at all like because i feel
like that was more of just them flexing
to be like guys we still made games
remember remember remember we made games
we were a [ __ ] real [ __ ] amazing
uh game developer back in the day we
could still do it we could still be good
we still got a video i played a lot of
games on the vr and super hot is still
probably the best yeah
that's the game that i get when people
come to my house and i'm like you want
to try out yeah super hot is the game
yeah yeah try this yeah because it's so
good yeah it's so good super hot and
beat saber which is the best vr
experience i've probably had yeah
so far it's
it's
i understand because like setting up the
valve index is like it's the best
headset right if you want performance
yeah gaming
but my god but like i i i think the k
one it is set that thing up and you need
a space big enough yeah which is another
reason why it like in japan is like not
popular at all no yeah i think my
problem with vr gaming that i've had so
far is that it turns gaming
uh for like for me gaming is like a
passive activity but vr gaming is
definitely an active activity for me
where i you know you feel physically
involved it doesn't feel like i like it
no i i do like that as well but like
that you know
when you have like a [ __ ] eight-hour
10-hour gaming session i don't want to
that that's like there's only so long i
can have yeah i can do something active
right for that period of time like to me
a lot of games are a passive activity
where you sit down on the couch or sit
at your pc you just like chill there i
think it also depends on like the the
demographic as well right like because
i'm sure like you know the average 10
year old has a lot more [ __ ] energy
to move around for eight to ten hours
yeah yeah yeah versus like you know
someone who's in like their 40s when i
played a gorilla tag
yeah it's just all like 10 year olds
yeah it's all 10 year olds well like you
know i think back to like when i was
well i think back to when i was 10 and
the [ __ ] uh you remember the i toy
the camera on ps2
like when that [ __ ] came out and you had
to like physically move around and [ __ ]
like you know that like as a 10 year old
that's like [ __ ] yeah i could do this
for hours if you got me an eye toy now
i'd probably be like an hour and a half
and i'm done yeah without that to me
that was always like a gimmick you know
like that that one time you go to like
your cousin's house and they pull out
the ddr map and you're like oh okay
we're having a ddr virtual boy yeah yeah
yeah right right
matt that like barely registered yeah
yeah yeah
it's like yeah you got a [ __ ] stamp
yeah
after like one like like one use or
something it's a shame because i think
that like vr gaming
is some of the most
fun and rewarding gaming
out
there there's no incentive for people to
develop games for it like it's hard and
also it's like you know when you're a
kid and you i don't know if you've ever
had them uh i don't know what they're
called in australia but in the uk the
brand calls like uh scale electrics it's
like the you know those cars you have to
lay out that track yeah and then you
have the oh hot wheels all right maybe
kind of like hot wheels you lay out the
track and then you have those things
that like you turn the buttons and they
go
around the [ __ ] thing what are they
called and what's the generic name for
them i think you're right
it's like that that's what vr feels like
right now
it needs to get to the point where
current gaming is where it feels like oh
did you put on the headset you're good
to go yeah right now it's like i have to
turn on the two base stations i have to
make sure all the cables are plugged in
oh i gotta install this update oh the
tracking's off i gotta fix the tracking
it's like it's such a it's like going
back to that feeling as a kid where you
set up that that track you set it all up
just for that like 30 minutes of
enjoyment yeah and then you got to put
it all away yeah so like and until it
gets to the point where it doesn't feel
like a slog to set up it's not that it's
active i think i think it's it's it's
like a pain in the ass to set up and i
know it is i've got mine set up now to
the point where it's as painless as
possible and it's still a pain in the
air yeah like
that five minutes of me turning
everything on and doing it all it's just
a little bit annoying for my my lazy
gamer brain to want to do well because
you're so used to just the the turn on
immediately start yeah right right yeah
that makes sense yeah uh it's called
skeleton uh that's the brand of yeah
yeah yeah yeah is there a generic name
for that kind of product or i think it's
just motorized cars yeah just like that
yeah you know how like as a kid i think
we had a really dodgy one and it was
just a whole event setting it up yeah
yeah it took so long yeah but like you
as i remember as a kid you had way more
patience you know right like not not
even as a kid but as a teenager as well
you know like you know i like you know i
tell people about the [ __ ]
uh the [ __ ] efforts i had to go
through to even just [ __ ] watch anime
or play some visual novels and you have
to you have to like download like seven
million zip files
three tutorials about how to like
install this game
i think back to that now i'm just like
man imagine like imagine trying to do
that now we can just press one button on
steam to like play play a lot of these
like japanese underground games and all
that well even like console games right
like you had to like go into the bin to
look for the cartridge of the game and
then you had to [ __ ] put it in oh
it's not working pull it out blow on it
a little bit put it back in turn it on
wait for it to load now you just [ __ ]
turn on your switch and the download
game is right there yeah but like i
thought i mean i buy my games cartridge
yeah oh really yeah i actually give them
to my like other people when i'm done
with them oh okay
but like a big thing that i've kind of
like felt recently is that
like i've kind of like thought what is
the direction that gaming is going to go
right what because i've uh i've recently
procured myself a playstation 5. i know
all right hello guys i know i know oh
you're the lucky few yeah the lucky few
and the reason i did that was entirely
because i was like i'm not gonna i don't
need a ps5 yet i don't need a ps5 and
then
horizon uh forbidden west came out and
horizon zero dawn is like one of my
favorite games of all time so i'm like
all right this kind of deserved the
special treatment i'll try and go out my
way to get a ps5 in order to play this
game yeah and
the game looks [ __ ] amazing it looks
[ __ ] fantastic right um but is it
is it that different from playing it on
a ps4 i wouldn't really say so you know
i i i feel like hyper realism in video
games has almost reached the limit to
the point where it's like yeah we can't
get any better graphics don't look that
much different yeah yeah um like eight
years ago yeah they don't they they
can't get any better than this like i
remember jumping from like i remember
the first time i got my n64 and i played
super mario 64. and like my mind [ __ ]
blew yeah it was like i was like like
running around in 3d after
after 2d mario or all this time like i
could not comprehend yeah i was such an
experience
like up is forward
right
what how does that work
and and now i'm just like i think there
are extra pixels that i'm that my eye is
seeing right now right i feel like you
have like a 12k like tv like yeah
i feel like it's a bit smoother because
there are slightly more frames but it's
only it suddenly isn't like the
mind-blown kind of experience that i
felt before but that's what i'm saying
like that that's why i feel like we've
almost reached that limit when it comes
to like amazing graphically how games
can be and that's why i feel like
especially the indie scene for the past
like 10 years has been more focused on
making these more like stylized games
like pixel games and stuff like that
like you know what i want back i want
cell shading in games back
can we have that back has it ever left
i think it's like it used to be in the
forefront i feel of like all the main
line games or like the main streams
in the way it was i think so i think for
like certain demographics like you know
like when like wind waker came out for
example everyone [ __ ] hated it at
first until they played and they
realized how amazing it was yeah i i
remember when everyone when wind waker
came out and there was so much
discussions in like magazines to be like
this is a step down
like this is a graphical step that's
what the trend was right it was realism
really yeah it wasn't real and then and
then when we started getting used to the
cell shader [ __ ] like with um what's it
uh lollipop chainsaw is like another
game series that's like very cell shaded
very stylized right yeah people were
also like oh man this game looks
too [ __ ] weird like it's it's it's
not
pretty enough and then people
immediately when they played the game
they found out oh you know what this is
pretty but just on a different caliber
of pretty yeah i mean like i would say
like wind waker has aged the best
visually in terms like i i i would argue
like pretty much every zelda game yeah
you know i mean i think it looks better
than pokemon and the best thing yeah
exactly and the best thing is those
kinds of styles a lot of the times are
ageless yeah like like a cuphead yeah oh
yeah exactly or like you know like wind
waker looks just as good in even in
today's standards because it's so
stylized whereas if you go back to like
you know uh ocarina of time right you
you're like you're like oh
not as pretty as my 12 year old my
background i thought it was a fugly game
yeah it's not a pretty so if you have
the context you know the setting and
stuff it makes sense of course you know
people who say like you know with all
those n64 games who are like no no it
looks just as good today or obviously
they're just operating off nostalgia
yeah right but like anyone can look at
mario 64 and go
[ __ ] me that's an ugly game yeah you
know yeah it just think mario's foot
looks kind of good
you see compared to like ocarina well
yeah like if you look at something like
goldeneye goldeneye looks awful oh that
looks beautiful
and you know and ocarina of time i think
it looks awful i don't know mario 64
like i i don't know why i think it looks
okay it i don't think it aged as bad as
you might think i think you you should
probably take like a closer look i have
i have i have because i was bouncing
looks like [ __ ] okay i'll give you that
bowser looks like [ __ ] the peach in the
opening scene i'm just like ah
what is that that is true actually
because when i when i think of mario 64
for some reason i go to mario sunshine
yeah because that was like i guess my my
childhood marriage yeah yeah i remember
and mary sunshine has aged a lot better
visually visually than mario 64 million
times better yeah
yeah because uh with yeah i feel like
that generation of games like um
i wouldn't say ps1 because like i look
back at like metal gear solid one and i
i look back at like pixels talking to
each other like snake's face does he
doesn't have detail it's like one
triangle it's just a triangle and i
remember thinking how the [ __ ] did i get
invested in these cut scenes of the
snake going articon and it's just like a
pixel going
you know but like i i feel like the ps2
gamecube era was kind of when we started
really
like
really getting to
getting to the point where i couldn't
see that much of a big jump in graphical
fidelity yeah yeah and then afterwards i
did see a difference with ps3
ps3 to me is when it kind of like peaked
you know where you know what last of us
originally came out on the ps3 right and
i was just like i to me like the
original last of us
like pretty much every game looks about
the same as last year yes you know even
though i could tell they look
graphically better they're not that much
graphically better that i think my god
this is a [ __ ] mind-blowing amount of
improvement yeah
he looks pretty bad though
that's because the wii had like very
limited hardware where are we in um
isn't it 480p the wii u i think i think
so it has a native resolution of 40.
yeah and it's just upscale yeah it looks
rough when you go back and play it
you're like oh because i remember as a
kid when super smash brothers melee no
uh brawl came out yeah remember i
thought dude this is like the pinnacle
i thought i thought that was a twilight
princess yeah insane yeah and i looked
back like a like a year ago and i was
like what the [ __ ] it looked like that
the entire time
i think because i'm i'm remembering the
rendered cutscenes for that game yeah
yeah the cut scenes look amazing yeah
because they're coming because of course
they're [ __ ] yeah but i think with in
the case with that generation of
consoles like the wii i think it depends
on the game as well because like
twilight princess still looks great even
though that's a wii game that's it i
think it still looks great i haven't
liked it but the competitor i think
every single footage i've seen try
princess of late has been the uh hd
remix
but if you look at it comparatively like
a lot of these like hd remasters i don't
really see the point of calling them hd
remasters because if you put them side
by side they're really unless you're
like a [ __ ] you know pixel snob like
you're not gonna see like you know when
uh final fantasy 10 remastered came out
right like the hd remaster yeah i played
it and i was like how does this look any
different to the ps2 version oh it's
like did you just did you see the uh the
gta
uh three remastered no that was a
disaster really it was like the game
load worse
did you all see this i didn't see this
it was like a massive controversy no i
didn't say this at all they like took
off the original grand theft auto and
you couldn't buy it right the original
third one yeah and they were like you
have to buy the remake they they
reversed it a little bit i can't
remember exactly what they did
but they released this remake and it
looked worse than the original it was
like they just turned like the
smoothness option on like everything had
just been smooth right right people just
looked even weirder in the cut scenes
and all of it looked have you not seen
the oh okay let me quickly grab a few
images and show you i'm going to type in
uh grandpa auto
gta 3 remaster
um images images
comparison
comparison okay
yeah so like look at this
this is the original and this is the
remastered
oh
that's gross that's just uncanny yeah
there's also yeah um there's so many
where like it doesn't look
like that much better yeah yeah it's
like
i i i'd say the original has more
character to it yeah yeah a lot of the
cut scenes the characters just look
worse yeah it was really weird i just
don't understand but that's the thing
with like again that's the thing with
like hd remasters right like when they
did this theory master of wind waker i
was like
this legitimately looks no different it
still looks just as good it does look a
bit crisper yeah
it's very minute though i would say
right like like you know compared to
like final fantasy vii and final fantasy
vii remake right like you know yeah
exactly like you know that's that's a
big that's a big jump yeah it's like
jumping it's a different remake and a
rematch right right it's true well yeah
they just kind of like
upped the contrast and smoothed it all
out and made it probably just higher
yeah yeah higher higher resolution but
like it's like a style it's so stylized
yeah that like in terms of like actual
graphical updates or upgrades it's like
it's not something to write home about
yeah if you look at the images it just
looks like the edges are smoother yeah
like rtx has been turned on well you
know you're not going to see that big of
a difference when you're playing the
game it wouldn't make a difference
experience play in the game not at all
yeah i mean i guess that's talking about
like the graphical differences as well
but in terms like gameplay differences i
feel like the gaming industry as a whole
has just like optimized pretty much like
90 of everything they can that can be
optimized and you know every so often we
get something like uh breath of the wild
that completely changes the way you look
at like an open world for example yeah
and now every open world game has a
glider for some reason even if it
doesn't need it
i feel like the technology is
less so focused on
making the things very uh high graphics
or making the textures more advanced
it's like i think right now a lot of the
technology from what i understand is
focused on like um like the the lighting
and stuff right so yeah making it so
when you put a character in a world that
you can add all of the effects naturally
so instead of having a beam of light and
you programming like the light is here
it's like
you program the room and then you have a
bunch of options to like turn on the
i've got the name of the lighting thing
is it's like it's like lighting where it
uses like the calculations like figure
out what would happen if like a ball
went in the way yeah reflection stuff i
think that's where a lot of the
advancements are being made not so much
in like the individual
um like assets makeup because yeah the
models that we have of characters in
games are very very high quality oh they
are yeah and they have been for a while
yeah the only thing that's left is
making how the models interact with the
world
more realistic if they want that or you
know whatever they want to do and so now
it's about making the machines that can
do these animations or do these things
built in and do them smoother from what
i understand i could be totally wrong
someone might correct that that's what i
want to know right it's like what's the
once we've perfected that hypothetically
what's the next step well that's why i
do look to vr because i do remember the
first time i tried beat saber and the
first time i tried superhot i did get
that same kind of feeling that i got
playing super mario 64 for the first
time which is just like your brain has
never experienced something like this
before and it's just [ __ ] pure
cocaine it was like
like the first time i played super vr
was like it's like one of the funnest
gaming experiences i've ever had yeah
like period absolutely but like that was
that was an hour or so or however long
it took me to play super bowl there's no
big games in vr actually yeah they're
all really good like one to three hours
where's the next mark where's the mario
vr game dude
i want to mario vr game where i am mario
it means that movement is limited
movement yeah you if you let like mario
kart vr was mario kart v yeah yeah it
could be i think there are racing games
in vr well they did it in uh they did it
in mario land so why can't they do it in
an oculus that was not very good though
that wasn't very good but
you know what i mean right like if we
get like a mario kart vr
i think right now like movement is
really hard yeah and when movement is
realistic it's not good
that's not what you want right but also
if you add unrealistic movement to your
character it becomes really hard to make
it feel real like that game i mentioned
where you jump around yeah you don't
jump around you just point the stick and
press jump because you can't do that
movement there's no i can't i can't jump
in my [ __ ] room like an engine right
i wish i could you know
i want to be on the sidelines watching
that yeah i wish i could i will never
get bored of like the random [ __ ] every
like random clips like that sometimes
get recommended on my youtube of like
grandma's trying vr for the first time
and like them doing like the balance
beam game or something just like jumping
head first into a wall jumping
[Laughter]
or like the grandma who like oh i think
it was a grandma or grandpa who did like
the the climbing one and uh they like
slowly fell
like they fell into like a table or
something
i know there's some places you can do it
and it's like an activity
the vr headsets that the cables go up to
the roof yeah and it's like a treadmill
you're standing yeah yeah yeah yeah like
an omni directional oh yeah
yeah you can't have a gun and then you
like run around
i know if there's one place in shinjuku
i think you can do that really yeah with
the treadmills
i know there's a few in america yeah it
looks really cool it looks really nice
really i like to try that out yeah like
imagine it's one where it's like a
trampoline that gives you like feedback
based on how much pressure you put on
the trampoline or something
kind of thing yeah because like i feel
like you're in gravity and the
trampoline gets stiffer yeah yeah and if
it's like less you know you're on like a
swan planet like yeah
that'd be cool i don't know how you do
that because like i've heard like one
technique that people use to combat
motion sickness in vr games right is to
literally drinking uh vitamin c
eating a [ __ ] ton of oranges eating a
[ __ ] heart pouring some salt
in their wounds
but uh also actually just like walking
like walking in the spot you know like
like just literally just literally
you're like just moving your legs to
make it feel like you're walking and
it's just weird that that just like
that is enough streak your brain into
thinking oh okay this is this is real
walking now i can understand this right
i've never done that before i should try
it i should try that i don't know
yeah i mean like it's it's vr right now
is
at the very new stages i'm very
interested to see
how and like if if gaming gets to a
point where this kind of does become
mainstream and we get some like actual
aaa games with vr games because yeah
right now
it seems like a very overpriced piece of
tech for a lot of tech demos
yeah that's a shame because i really
like it i really want it to evolve
but i think it's going to be where i i
think it would be really sick and
mainstream for like another 10 years at
least i'm just waiting man i want sword
online
i'm going to be jamming in vr when it's
out man oh yeah yeah i want to be that
that dad that is like in like doing his
pc stuff all the time playing games i'm
i'm going to be that dad of course of
course we're going to be the generation
when we're retired we're like oh finally
i can get started on that back catalog
of games right yeah aren't we getting
close to the year that sword arsenal
line was set now as well 2025 i think
yeah something like that i mean it could
be done just like i don't know how i
remember just like just hook a wire up
to your like pc or something that like
electrocutes you if you die in the game
it's like
like you actually just like gives you
like a like like a shock
it gives you a lethal voltage if you die
in the game like we could just do we
could probably do it now we just don't
because we're scared of what we could
create i'm sure there's something we're
scared of in advancements in technology
2022 so this year oh this year actually
this
is this year let's go
i i actually read i think they're
releasing like someone's releasing an
mmo the first vr mmo
oh my god it's real it's real it's real
we can barely make good mmos
now i hope i get selected as a beater
you are a better chance
but yeah i hate to date the video but uh
i just want to talk about this one thing
uh that i saw on twitter this morning
right uh
[Music]
old news by the time so probably all
news by the time this comes out but i
just couldn't [ __ ] believe it um
snoop dogg
has joined faze clan
what i'm not even joking
he has joined face clan as
faze snoop
okay okay what do you think about okay
okay i might be out of touch here yeah
what is a face client well like i know
face clan but
i don't know facetime what are face clan
like like what is a phase called what
it's um you know it's a it was
originally a youtuber organization and
now it's an esports organization right
yeah and then so so they always had it
was back in the day when cod started
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's how it started i
followed it then but like they've seemed
to like
just gone out of that little bubble i
don't know what phase is anymore i don't
know either are they just like a like a
youtube house
no it's like a brand and you know if you
if you're
anointed interface anointed
united interface you get uh
you do genuinely get a lot of success
yeah yeah it's a very powerful brand
yeah with younger audiences normally
yeah yeah
not
a lot of people
our age watch facebook are they still 15
16 yeah are they still an esports
organization or yeah they do everything
it's kind of like a brand you know
there's okay that's kind of what that
that's it's like an agency yeah so it's
from what i understand it's more of an
agency right but but all of the esports
brands
are all kind of going that way right now
because they realize that relying only
on esports is not the best for business
yeah because you can you know if your
team competes only four times six times
a year that's you you have to you can
only monetize the sponsors and then
those events yeah whereas if you're
you're an entertainer you can monetize
every time they upload or do something
yeah
i mean now it just seems like a lot of
esports organizations are just streamer
organizations because that's that's what
i feel would like with phase phase clan
now i'm just like are they still the
esports organization or the uh
entertainment i always thought it was
like amazing i always thought it was
like you know kind of like uh factioned
off whereas like these like we have a
bunch of face clan members who are like
the esports players who don't go on
twitch or youtube or anything yeah and
then we have the youtubers and then we
have the twitch streamers and then you
know well a lot of the time as well they
they want to get
the the best players in
a game or a genre because
normally the best players at any game if
they stream they will have an audience
yeah
not necessarily always but they've a lot
better chance of getting an audience
right right you know yeah you can kind
of help them and coach them through it
well they're definitely going to get a
bigger audience now now that snoop doo
double g has joined i don't know for
some reason when i heard that i'm just
like that doesn't sound surprising to me
i don't know why i don't know why i'm
just like does some interesting
i'm sure the deal is very good for snoop
oh yeah i'm sure it's an extremely good
deal i'm sure he needs the money
well to me has the same energy of uh do
you remember like back when you know uh
when e3 happened and you'd see like
these press conferences and then like at
every like e3 presentation they'd be
they'd have this like run one random
celebrity come on to promote their games
like i don't know like [ __ ] drake
promoting madden or something you know
what i mean yeah that it has the same
energy as that for me it does yeah where
you just get like this random
whether this random celebrity to promote
your brand or to your game
um and it wouldn't make any sense but
you know i just it makes
it it makes sense because it's so it's
such meme worthy that people are going
to talk about it anyway oh yeah of
course and sleep dog has done plenty of
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah i mean he's so
amazingly in touch with like internet
audiences and just meme culture that
like he's it's just like a win for him
it's just i don't know there's something
weird about
this is something weird about when he's
always we have to call him face snoop
now he's always posting on instagram and
stuff and all that
and he like like doxed his uber driver
or something what he like doxxed his
like delivery or door dash person yeah
because they didn't like deliver the
food right he like showed a picture in
their first name
to all of his followers oh my god
because he was shown the interaction
that he i think super dog was upset that
they didn't deliver the food and i think
snoop was trying to tell him where to go
all right because obviously snoop lives
in like a
gated community right it's probably a
bit harder to give it to him yeah yeah
and he was like complaining on his
twitter and showed the face and name of
the person and this guy got like a lot
of hate i think jesus poor guy poor guy
i don't know just
for me it's like really fascinating just
watching these like very
traditional celebrities and like music
artists and whatnot like kind of really
dig their heels into things like twitch
and youtube and stuff like that you know
like when i found out like you know
t-pain
regularly streams on twitch and he has
like a pretty [ __ ] massive order he
plays streams on twitch yeah t-pain
t-pain is massive on twitch dude like he
he's been streaming
constantly right like like everyone
wonders oh what happened to t-pain he's
on twitch now
he's just streaming like dead mouse as
well he's just streaming on twitter i
know deadmau5 streams on twitch and it's
just i don't know it's really bizarre
that like uh at least i find it very
bizarre to see these like people who
usually ever see yeah the people you'd
only ever see on like tv shows and like
music videos and stuff like that it's
just suddenly being like
oh yeah you know i just dropped a five
dollar donation to t-pain the other day
on twitch you know
this is weird to say out loud i don't
know d-pain stream
he's streamed 1400 hours he's got the
analytics up i'm looking at i'm looking
at a real streamer boy here yeah
he's uh
he's active normally one day a week one
day okay and normally uh
he shoots quite well i think i'm sure
he's i'm sure he's busy doing other
things sure he's streaming
right
he's
oh wow yeah he's quite active yeah
i was surprised i just ran because i
remember i was just like going through
twitch one day and you know like the
channels you should watch thing you know
came up and on the top of it it just
said t-pain i was like that can't be the
same t-pain right the guy who wrote
through the fire in flames
oh the guitarist for dragon force yeah
he streams the guitarist and the drummer
actually
really regularly i remember they wanted
to perform their song but they couldn't
for copyright reasons yeah yeah that's
that sounds like it sounds like the age
of the internet yeah right copyright
laws are broken yeah no like i remember
like when uh
well they weren't
yeah when like gordon ramsay replied to
xqc or something
about the cooking thing that that was so
surreal
i don't think that's called i'm pretty
sure that's just someone managing his
account but i think gordon has very good
people in charge i don't know because
gordon's pretty active on like tick tock
right he's pretty active on like social
media platforms
that he's he's he's keeping up with it
yeah i think gordon has a very good team
of
zoomers
like teaching him and telling him what
to do because like in this in one of his
videos he just kept talking about uncle
roger and i was like you obviously have
someone who's like keeping you in touch
and telling you
well obviously yeah we've talked about
how whoever they've hired for like the
kitchen nightmares um titles on youtube
right yeah like top ten times the food
was busting yeah
like that was like an actual youtube
title like what is happening
and it worked it worked it got so many
[ __ ] views yeah it's like a [ __ ]
decade old show now or something
the people running
his accounts are like on top of their
[ __ ] oh yeah i i i don't even want to
know how much the kitchen nightmares
youtube account makes cause i've noticed
as well the youtube kitchen nightmares
account
literally just repost the same clips
with different titles and different
montages all the time really they'll be
like
chopped ten times the burger was good
and then i'll then next we'll be like
top ten times the food was good and
they'll just reuse the same clips yeah
yeah so they just keep making different
lists and then
timeline there i always got time i would
even if i've seen this clip like 10
million times before all right how
awesome is it actually i gotta find out
nightmares
oh my god and i think another one was
like when the food wasn't busted top ten
times the food wasn't busting
right kitchen nightmares gets
on average or uh fluctuates from
anywhere between
30 to 70 million views a month holy [ __ ]
right
that's probably in the range of like uh
it could be anywhere from like a hundred
to two hundred grand a month well yeah
knowing how well food channels do yeah
it's probably two hundred thousand two
hundred
dollars yeah which is what which makes
me wonder why don't more reality tv
shows post as many [ __ ] clips as they
possibly can well because a lot of the
production team are out of touch or
maybe some copyright issues
probably a mixture of things also
probably a lack of faith that they'll do
well yeah yeah you know kids nightmares
brand is still very strong
yeah
like what what show were you thinking of
specifically like pretty much any
reality tv show i feel like big brother
like 90 day fiance yeah you know like
any basically anything made by tlc
like [ __ ] the bachelor like [ __ ] like
that like i feel like reality tv in like
especially reality tv was meant to be
watched in a group well tlc uploads
clips
all the time that's why they're so they
do so well because they upload all the
clippable moments that's that's how 90
day fiance got big to begin with right
it's because the clips went viral i
would like i i wonder if it would do
even better on like if they
not only uploaded whole episodes but
like uploaded a whole episode uploaded
clips uploaded like [ __ ] montages
like with the kitchen nightmare things
because it feels like
this kind of content is just infinitely
recyclable because it's content that
you're gonna [ __ ] watch whenever you
have like a lunch and you need to sit
down and you're like what clip do i want
to watch oh maybe i'll just watch
kitchen nightmares maybe i'll just watch
nine state fiance again the same [ __ ]
big head clip or whatever you know
you never get tired of them you're just
you'll just never get tired of that yeah
the clip of somebody who's over like 600
pounds yeah
or someone with like a gross uh you know
obsession or yeah
coffee animal i like smelling butt holes
thank you
was it like what was that show like my
weird my session
gets me every time i'm just like there's
no way someone actually does that and
they do
and like gross the one thing that makes
me cringe the most for some reason is
the
it was this one british woman who eats
concrete
oh yeah yeah yeah and it wasn't the fact
that she was just better than british
food
that is a british delicacy right
developing a strong jawline with that
one yeah yeah you told me they were like
why do legos have do not eat warnings
and british food doesn't
[Music]
validate that's true no it was just like
the noise that it made when she was
crunching oh she was crunchy
yeah i can hear she have any
you know that feeling where you
accidentally get sand in your mouth and
it's just like
i don't know it's just the worst problem
[Music]
feeling alone that feeling i understand
anakin for that one for that one moment
where you accidentally get sand in your
mouth and you just spend the next five
minutes just like oh there's just a
weird crunch in there yeah i can't get
rid of it i think maybe the reason why
like a lot of like you know shows like
that reality tv shows don't post clips
and full episodes i think it's because a
lot of they're like this is just
speculation but i'm guessing a lot of
like the producers and the production
team and the people behind the actual
show still have some level of faith that
people still watch tv like they used to
back in the day and so they're like well
i mean we're still getting numbers maybe
not as big as you know back in the
oughts but you know people still
watching tv i also imagine that maybe if
you're producing a lot of shows i
imagine there has been a lot of shows
that just lost because they didn't
archive them properly or they didn't
yeah they didn't they don't have the
files or they they have them they just
don't know what which one's which i
imagine there's a lot of that going on
probably
copyright you know like maybe the
production team made it and then sold it
to a network and maybe the network
doesn't have the rights and the
production team doesn't uh maybe they
also don't have the rights for them and
i'm sure they didn't build those
contracts you know with the clause of
like oh you know if these go on youtube
then we hold all right sure they do now
a lot of networks pretty dear but i
don't i don't yeah but like a show from
the 2000s probably not
yeah like i noticed right now especially
like whenever i go on my netflix holy
[ __ ] they make a lot of reality tv shows
like with like every single genre right
it doesn't matter yeah i remember when
netflix is like an occupation this is
probably a reality show
you watched that one no no there's a
glass one there's a glass blowing like
because there is like competition i
watched like the full series i don't
know why did i have like the reality tv
like interviews it was like masterchef
with glasgow oh my god and they had like
the archetypes of the glass-blowing
judges they were like the you know like
the gordon ramsay the
the nice one the mean one i can't
believe he just said that about my face
[Music]
is it like exactly the same format and
everything like that yeah but like you
have now 30 minutes to make your your
glass it is literally like a master chef
but replaced with glass blood oh my god
it wasn't that bad because it got blown
away yeah blown away
blown away how many seasons have you got
now
let me see
oh yeah
i remember when like netflix was like
just [ __ ] out like five
documentaries a day and now they've
they're like shutting out five different
reality tv shows today
i've got a season two and no game no
life didn't like what the [ __ ] i'm
surprised that like every single
death in the us hasn't had a docu series
at this rate like
everything has been covered at this
point yeah honestly i just don't it's
crazy like i watched one the other day
about like some uh grandma who uh was
killing people in her house and i was
like
how are they finding this stuff who's
finding this this is insane why was this
not televised earlier i feel like i
should know about this grandma are
killing people this feels like a yeah
like a tv show plot yeah this happened
on tv would be like unrealistic
obviously you don't watch enough true
crime documentaries or true crime
podcasts or channels
the obsession sometimes you're watching
true crime you're like
and then you just get this moment of
like your your consciousness going don't
you think it's weird that you're
watching stories about people being
murdered and they're just shoving
cameras in their face and interrogating
people to tell tell us how they felt 20
years ago when their family member died
like do you not get that when you watch
it yeah definitely i feel like i get
these moments i'll watch a full series i
won't get it every now and then i'll
just watch a series and it's always with
the family interviews where it kind of
makes me think
what why are they just making these
family members just like [ __ ] talk
about their [ __ ] and cry on camera
oh like they're like
i loved him and stuff and it's like it's
genuine right and i feel like these
these poor people who like yeah didn't
ever want to talk about this again have
just been shoved with it because they're
probably when someone was like here's 10
grand talk about your dead cousin yeah
and how they were close to you and how
it was suspicious that that one guy who
never got caught was you know that
brutal myrtle that you saw in front of
your eyes recall that yeah word for word
and it's just the same formula as well
yeah i don't know it feels like we've
turned it into a sort of
location like yeah we've glorified
murder and stuff and
yeah that's scary i feel like like
because sydney i've talked about this
before but sydney listens to a lot a lot
of like true crime videos true crime
podcast whenever like she's doing her
makeup and stuff like that and like
every so
and then david trapped sally in her
basement for two weeks and brutally
her before
her
but before i get to the next point i'd
like to bring up my sponsor for today's
video nordvpn and i'm just like brah
what is this right now okay like i i get
it like you know like the you know
i don't know if these guys like i don't
even know if an expo i know rainbow has
sponsors and stuff like certainly i
understand like yeah i get it but it you
have to admit it
is it's so jarring when i just hear
about this this like i love channels by
the way i love your guys's videos
but there's but there's right and wrong
places to put it i don't know it's so
wet i don't think there's ever like uh
unfortunately the topic i think just
doesn't lend one yeah it just doesn't
land well but like there's there's been
weird transitions i mean we've done very
many weird transitions in i'm sure in
our careers with like just transitioning
to a uh sponsor that we've had for this
video
the berserk thing one time right we were
talking about the passing of
uh oh yeah and because the way that we
recorded it uh there was an ad break
that was put right in the middle of us
talking about
uh
yeah
something that we looked over um
but there's yeah it's
not any like true crime
true crime youtubers they're i don't
know i don't think there is a right way
to transition from some of the stuff
they talk about to an advertiser yeah
every time i hear it it's just like it
just takes me out for a second it's just
like we've i don't know in a way i i
it's totally fine and i don't think it's
like bad i'm not condemning it no i'm
not condemning it i like i like the
content yeah but like you have to admit
sometimes you're watching it and you're
like it is strange how we've turned this
into like it's it's like the common
common day watch mojo yeah we've turned
in like that we've turned murders into
what we we like top tens used to fill
like
whereas top 10 used to fill that i'll
just put anything on kind of thing yeah
just like murder and horrible acts just
let it fill the void somehow
like there's a there's like channels i'm
surprised watching mojo hasn't gone into
that yeah there's top 10 like girls
who've been trapped in dungeons
there's probably something i know
there's people who do their makeup and
talk about true crime that's a call yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've seen that a lot yeah
which is also a strange evolution but
impressive it's like get ready with me
while i talk about this it's horrible
it's like cool
it's like next level mukbang right but
they're just
they're doing makeup and they're talking
about true questions i want to see a
mukbang where they talk about true crime
as they're like just demolishing your
pilot
i bet you're saying this i bet it
already exists
don't give nicaragua avocado any more
ideas man don't don't come on nick is
publishing a live true crime whatever
he's doing his body is through [ __ ]
crime that's the true crime documentary
that's true crime what he's doing is
this digestive system jesus christ yeah
i mean again like i i watch a lot of it
i consume a lot of it but i do just get
those moments where i'm like
yeah the reality hits right yeah
it is weird especially where like i
thought about it the other day and i'm
like i don't know anyone
in my immediate circle or relatives or
anything
where somebody has had like something
really horrible happen to them or a
murderer i don't know do you know anyone
like a cousin who knows someone who's
been murdered or something like that no
not when it comes to murder and like
this this true crime stuff almost kind
of like normalizes it in your mind i
feel like that this is a normal thing
that happens i don't think in fact it
isn't normal no and i think it
normalizes it it just desensitizes you
to it yeah well i mean it makes you
think that it is a normal thing that
happens really i've never heard of like
i've never listened to true crime and
thought it was a normal thing that
happened like you watch it these are
real people like yeah yeah these people
these interviews this could be your this
could be your cousin this could be your
mom like this i think i think it's the
gravity at which they address that
particular topic where it's like they
they say like oh yeah so uh tim got
murdered like
in the same tone as like yeah so i met
up with bob the other day you know yeah
it's like i think yeah i think the
gravity of the situation is often lost
yeah in in the content because there's
so much content like that yeah yeah the
content is king and
yeah and i'm not saying that i want to
sit there and feel traumatized every
single time i watch something about true
crime i just think it's kind of
interesting and worth talking about the
fact that we don't consume it and we
don't
empathize
necessarily always yeah i mean it is
entertainment in
in a sense right it is entertainment we
do we don't watch it to really how can i
say it's really s
we don't we don't watch it
to not sympathize but we don't watch it
people don't watch these kinds of
documentaries and cry at the end of it
right is what you know like they don't
they're not like oh my god i feel so sad
for these like families start we watch
out of morbid curiosities yeah like
there's there's a sense of morbidness to
it where we want to know the gross
details did curiosity go though that's
the question that's the question well
that's when you start getting into the
weird [ __ ] right yeah yeah and uh that's
the part where it's like oh okay
yeah to the point where it's like oh
true you liking true crime documentaries
is nothing compared to like
some of the weirdest stuff you're into
sometimes i wonder like
like do
i think i'm consuming this content wrong
because i've watched some things where
it'll be like a documentary and it'll be
like oh yeah like a kid got like beat up
by his parents and no one helped him and
then the kid died and it's like i have
to like stop for the day yeah i'm like i
have to like take a yes i have to like
just step back and be like [ __ ] yeah i
can't do anything but then people will
watch like tons of these and i'm like
i'm wondering like what are they
experiencing that's different from me
yeah like that that makes it so that i
walk away from this just feeling drained
and exhausted yeah and they're like oh
next one
yeah
one thing i found really just want to
know like yeah one thing i found really
interesting is that japan doesn't have
any programming like that no they don't
they don't i've noticed that yeah and i
think it's because it's taboo yeah it is
it is taboo to like bring it back up and
talk about it and especially like you
know i can't imagine a [ __ ] tv
program being like knock knock knock hey
your son got murdered 10 years ago talk
about it like you know like they want to
respect the families right yeah it's
like not saying that you know all of
these like two true crime documentary
makers have no respect on the families
or whatever but it is scarily like
it is it feels invasive at times yes it
does
it feels very
intimate yeah and it's scary that no one
who watches that kind of programming
second guesses
that invasiveness but also i understand
maybe if somebody was your family was
murdered i can also understand the the
opposite where being able to talk about
it and express your faith
can help you get like grieve and help
you kind of get the story out there and
you feel like i've told my case i've
told people what it is and i'm sure both
sides yeah and i'm sure you know the
ones who think that oh if i just talk
about it on camera and get it off my
chest and let people hear it it would
make me feel better they're the ones
that turn into documentaries that's why
i kind of get worried with these sorry
i've interrupted like three times in a
row now
the final time i promise i promise
unprofessional i know i remember what i
said like most of the time i had like a
point and it was gone and i was like oh
man i have no appointments
connor let god [ __ ] you speak
you know that's another thing addressed
him i think a few of them here and there
is like this is where i i start to get a
bit weirded out with true crimes when
there's the true crime investigators
online that go around and then start you
know pushing buttons and sending emails
and asking people questions who don't
want to talk about it it's like i think
people have it right board warriors
keyboard investigation detectives what
was that [ __ ] what was that one where
that guy
oh
[ __ ] which one was it there was this guy
who's like that the head detective for
the online and um do you know what have
you watched this was sydney's probably
definitely [ __ ] laughing i got acid
they don't [ __ ] with cats
that was the only one i know well that
was actually a good one yeah there's
been another one where a guy
was just like a 4chan user or something
i needed i don't feel confident saying
about it i need to go and check
what it was on netflix there's one where
this guy was basically like like in
charge because the police weren't
helping that much but the police have to
go through you know systems and right
they don't always do the best job
obviously they have to go through the
procedure this guy kind of like
kind of steamrolled in and was like i'll
help you family i'll be the detective
and it was kind of weird watching this
documentary what was the family like
they were like oh yes they liked it
because
they were in a vulnerable spot you know
this guy was selling them the thing that
i can help you know that's not cool but
but i think the guy genuinely believed
he could help i don't think he was a
scam or anything because there was no
money involved he was like i will help
you but it just felt kind of weird okay
i was about safe like he was like i'll
help you solve the game
he was like an internet guy who's just
really into true crime and he was going
about being like i will solve this i'll
help you do it okay [ __ ] i need to
figure out what this is i've i have a
such a vivid image of this guy i don't
know do you do you think that's morally
correct to do or
it might have been um i don't know it
really depends on the situation because
was this guy deluded or did this guy
actually help out i don't know what
grounds i guess what
what uh from what has described what
grounds did he have to uh come to a
family and was like i can solve this
crime did he want the clout
right so the next time he's on a true
crime
so uh you might have heard of this case
that was me it's from tiger king 2 oh
there's this guy who was like oh yeah
i'm i'm definitely certain that uh
carol basking killed it yeah i'll help
the family and stuff i'm just weird it
was just like this guy's clearly just
inserting himself yeah in the situation
he just wants to be part of the
storyline it's just like it was just
like i just
i just
i don't know just leave it up to the
professionals yeah like to me i think i
get too invested in true crime stories
which is why i've never fully like been
into true crime uh because like i i
would hear some of the stuff that sydney
listens to or something and sometimes
they like actually play like the 9-1-1
call that is made about this crime and i
hear this [ __ ] and i'm like i'm just
like fresh out of the shower ready for
my day or something and i got like a
like like a kid [ __ ] crying on the
phone telling like the police that her
mother's been murdered or something i'm
like and then you immediately feel dirty
i'm just like sydney i want to cry now
can we not listen to what she's like
[Laughter]
like
i'm
how far have you guys gone with like
your morbid curiosities right because
the internet is a wonderful but
sometimes a terrifying place where you
can see anything you want to see yes
right um and i know a lot of people a
lot of kids went through a phase where
they they stumbled upon like the darker
sides of the internet right like you
know because i'm not even gonna pretend
to sugarcoat the fact that like yeah you
know at one point when i was in high
school someone was like do you know of
this thing called tor and i was like no
what's that and so i downloaded it and i
was like oh it's a gateway to the dark
web
and you know i spent an afternoon one
afternoon on tour you know going through
the dark web just to see how [ __ ] up
it was and uh
can confirm that's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] on
there yeah cause like for me like i like
i didn't do anything like no no no
i didn't enjoy it joey incriminates
himself i didn't do anything i just i
saw a lot of things that i probably
shouldn't have seen right yeah like like
even to me like my baseline i could not
go on like if i see a live league thing
i'm clicking off that video no no i just
i just like i've never had that kind of
part of myself where i was morbidly
curious enough to see something that i
probably would regret i can live the
rest of my life not seeing this i've
seen the worst things on twitter
yeah yeah that's i'll be honest
with you the most [ __ ] up videos i've
ever seen have been on twitter actually
that's true some
really [ __ ] up things and i'm i
thought you were just like being
facetious there i thought i thought
i thought you were just like oh i had
this tweet i saw the other day like
friends like like people who i i
followed and i knew they'd like retweet
and be like oh this is horrible it's a
video of like some people getting shot
and stuff yeah yeah yeah i've seen that
[ __ ] why are you sharing this yeah i've
i've actually seen that as well i
thought you would be physicians to be
like i saw this tweet the other day and
said that demons better than jesus
oh my god
[Music]
i definitely saw the most haunting stuff
being shared on twitter yeah yeah
twitter is very slow to get rid of this
stuff yeah yeah it's nearly as good as
other platforms
and uh yeah all the [ __ ] [ __ ] there
man i yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've never been on net
i've never been on the dark web i don't
really have an interest i
don't weirdly enough like
the stuff i saw on the dark web just
like just based on like what you see as
an image or whatever is not as [ __ ] up
as some of the stuff you'd see on like
reddit the second page of google i'm
just i'm kidding
no one talks about kidding yeah
no it's just like i think it's just like
i think the thing that's like [ __ ] up
about the dark web from my experience on
going on it is just like there's
conceptually a lot of [ __ ] up things
yeah like when you read into it it's
like oh how about you people buying
drugs
that's like ninety percent that's like
the people selling an ftc
you know there's
but like you know there's like a lot of
other stuff you'd look into and it's
like oh where it's like okay i probably
didn't want to know that that was an
operation that is currently functioning
right now it's somewhere out there in
the world you know levels are [ __ ] up
whereas like you go live link in twitter
it's like you're immediately exposed to
something that's like oh that's oh i
shouldn't have seen like i didn't want
to see a guy's head explode on live leak
but i just did yeah well it's just like
there's one of the few times that a
video like that or a picture has like
like gone through the cracks you know
it's just like it's never not been
haunting for me in like every way shape
from like i remember every [ __ ]
[ __ ] up thing i see because i see it
once and i'm just like that is now like
[ __ ] ingrained in my mind and that
would be a point where i'm in the shower
i have like a [ __ ] flashback to that
video i'm like my day is just infinitely
worse and i'm just like
but there's a part of me there where
like i know this is reality and i know
like the internet is filtered so yeah it
is more friendly but like there's a part
of me where i'm just like i don't want
to be desensitized to this thing you
know because i know i i've met some
people who are just like you think
that's baby [ __ ] i've seen the real [ __ ]
i've seen the [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've seen
the snuff film why and i'm just like
well
to me like
i like being sensitive to this stuff
right because this [ __ ] is it grounds me
yeah this [ __ ] grounds you and like the
true crime stuff as well like to me at
least like to me i don't want to be too
desensitive to the group to the true
crime stuff in case
in case this happens in my real life and
i know someone that has that has
happened
that it happens to you i don't i don't
want to be desensitized to that in my
mind so let's be real like you know if
some person comes up to you and says
like oh well that's that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] i've seen the more [ __ ] up stuff
i'm like that's not a brag
like why do you think you're cool
because you've seen like a bunch of live
league videos and you're not facebook i
want to leave yeah like that doesn't
make that that's not going to make me be
like oh my god what an absolute [ __ ]
mega chat this guy is like sitting
through a bunch of lively playlists it's
like no that just makes me not want to
be near you because you're [ __ ] weird
is it lovely shut down now yes
i believe it has really since when
i
what a good thing damn missed out
yeah no it's horrible but yeah i don't
know it's just like because there was
you know especially during like the the
peak of like right at 50 50 right yeah
like the
mid-2010s remember when that was the
crosstalk explain what we read at
i i don't i kind of don't want it
because i don't want people going on to
it is this still a thing i don't know
i think it's salty but red 5050 is
basically it's this subreddit where
people post this like link
uh where it's like it's like you have a
50 50 chance when you click the link of
it's a really nice thing or it's a
really bad thing and when i say nice and
bad i mean like really nice and like the
worst nf nsfl [ __ ] you will ever see
like straight from lively so there's you
know an example would be like
uh write a 50 50. uh five cute puppies
or five decapitated heads
and you won't know which one it is until
you click the link yeah yeah and uh in
the 2010s that was a game people like
kids used to play you know like i
remember some of my [ __ ] high school
friends or like you know in a skype call
back in the day was like you want to do
a little bit of red 5050 as if they're
inviting me to like a minecraft server
you know like it's like yeah yeah it's
just casual gaming you know
and uh you know poor naive me the first
time around uh i was like no what's
reddit 50 50. biggest mistake in my life
i did that for five minutes i was like i
don't wanna i don't wanna i don't wanna
talk to you guys ever again for letting
me sit through that because i was
horrible
and uh yeah and then it became a big
thing on [ __ ] youtube yeah which is
why i feel sorry for like like the one
of the worst jobs i could imagine is the
people who work for moderate rate of
feed
nice [ __ ] stuff right yeah yeah you
have to have to have to go through every
video that's been flagged oh yeah
in facebook
there was a video i saw of like
something it's not it was a vice versa
yeah yeah yeah yeah like like one of
these people who had been interviewed
yeah
they had to like go through that job
seems like the worst job on earth it's
just like completely desensitized like
just hearing them talk they're just like
apparently yeah obviously you'd have to
like go through a bunch of uh really
horrific views and
really uh [ __ ] up really right
opinions i think i think yeah apparently
like a lot of them would like get really
desensitized and become like really
[ __ ] up the more they do this job i
think i think it was that vice
documentary where like the girl said
that like oh yeah once you apply for
this position you just like immediately
like get therapy yeah like it just comes
with the package it comes with the
package yeah that there is a therapist
yeah
like maybe on slime maybe online i don't
know but like a terrifying thought i
know there's a job out there that
immediately requires you to have therapy
yeah we're kind of like you they need
the like they're they're the [ __ ]
real heroes oh yeah there needs to be
someone out there that makes the [ __ ]
internet safer for people like us that
don't want to see that on our timeline
otherwise you know what's the difference
between the normal web and the dark web
at that point right like yeah yeah yeah
exactly just exactly the same thing
exactly right i just hope they're
getting treated [ __ ] fairly and
treated well and getting paid well i
hope this is a [ __ ] horrible job i
hope they get the best [ __ ] therapist
that's a that's a sad thing right my god
if they don't have the best [ __ ]
therapists on the planet like jesus
christ it's not worth
i didn't mean to make uh the ending of
the podcast that morbid we went through
some weird topic i feel like i say that
every episode
that was a weird tangent it wasn't you
know sometimes you go you tangent on in
the happy end and sometimes you tangent
on the weird and dark ends and uh
unfortunately or not that was one of the
podcasts where tangents in tula hey man
that's
you'll never know what we're going to
talk about next you never know i'm sorry
we'll talk about shooting next week just
to just to brighten things up we'll talk
about [ __ ] just i just [ __ ] myself
speaking of bright spots though look at
these patrons look at that they they
make us happy they bring a smile off
they make me forget about the horrible
[ __ ] i saw on the dark web so thank you
for that
your contribution gives me joy
but uh yeah if you like to support the
show and all the things all the messed
up things we talk about sometimes then
go over to our patreon patreon.com also
follow us on twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you enjoy our
face or if you hate our face let's
tussle spotify if you enjoy our face
watch us on youtube like you are now yes
all right well thank you for watching
all right next week bye
[Music]
you